tras la segunda victoria consecutiva de
manuel manjón que a pesar de la gran
división entre el electorado francés
renovará como presidente de francia
algunos ciudadanos albergan miedos temen
que se desate una nueva oleada de
descontento social
espera una crisis social bastante más
grave de la del mandato anterior
limonada pop porque
escriba para mucho
[Música]
porque macro no hace lo que dice porque
miente creo que mientras los ciudadanos
a ver si aplica la reforma de pensiones
algo que lo veo complicado
activa un derecho
y es que macro ha sido criticado por
falta de políticas sociales conocido por
sus detractores como el presidente de
los ricos entre 2018 y 2019 tuvo que
enfrentar algunas de las mayores
manifestaciones que vivió el país en
décadas las de los chalecos amarillos un
episodio que algunos creen que pueda
repetirse
me temo que tendremos que esperar nuevos
impuestos aumento en la inflación debido
a la guerra en ucrania los franceses ya
tienen un problema de poder adquisitivo
algunos tienen problemas para
alimentarse así que me temo que podría
haber una nueva crisis de chalecos
amarillos
el mandatario fue reelegido en abril a
pesar de la oposición a sus políticas
empresariales ya la polémica propuesta
de aumentar la edad de jubilación de los
62 a los 65 años medidas que sólo podría
aplicar si mantiene la mayoría en las
elecciones legislativas de junio en las
que competirá con la coalición de
izquierdas liderada por la francia e
insumisa de melanson